yeah i feel like i have been pregnant
forever but people forget you have to
cook a baby for 10 months
i'm holding on to the railings of stairs
a lot harder than i was
i actually said to my doctor um well now
i'm 58 weeks pregnant and i didn't mean
it
i was like i thought i was 58 oh he's
pregnant
yeah baby
yeah katie's already past her due date
the bubblegum pink
nursery is ready and so is first time
girl dad orlando
what do you look forward to most about
raising your daughter i'm just excited
to be able to
raise her in a different way that i was
raised and to
let her think for herself and have
choice
we're here to support her just lean into
the magic of life and probably
dress like whatever she wants to dress
like for halloween
that's gonna be really really important
i was never allowed to go
trick-or-treating
or not or dressing up that's probably
why i make up for it so much
yeah um i was in church girl you know
all about it
for the 35 year old becoming a mom
doesn't mean she's giving up her career
a lot of people have asked me are you
going to like go away or whatever and
i'm like
i mean doesn't beyonce have like three
kids and she's still putting out black
as king
i got my cup you know like she's doing
the best she
her whole life is amazing i don't feel
like you have to
choose between what you love and what
you love and i would hope that
my happiness is her happiness and her
happiness is my happiness
i'm still pregnant it's not just taco
bell
times ted all right rolling this
is not a match katie shared some behind
the scenes from the making of her music
video
it was shot with a small mask wearing
crew making sure to keep her baby safe
her new album smile drops friday i love
you
don't touch your face i'm so excited for
both deliveries both obviously the child
and obviously the record i mean i don't
know who's going to come first her
or the record we'll see what kind of
headlines she wants she wants a
she wants to be the opener or the closer
i have a feeling she does not follow you
know
now you'll be celebrating the 10th
anniversary of teenage dreams your
iconic album
night do i look 10 years older
no time has been very good to you
um time and doctors